Hello, I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward for Going Green...
...where you are about to learn more about recycling than you even cared to know.
It goes in here.
But where does it go from there?
(MRFs) material recovery facilities, and there are a variety of those now in the area,...
...have used technology to sort the various components.
That means paper, plastic, cardboard, metal cans, almost anything can be tossed into the recycle bin.
Erik Grabowsky is with Arlington County's solid waste division.
We're trying to make it very convenient for our citizens.
We have what we call an "Integrated Solid Waste Management" program...
...which provides a comprehensive level of service to our citizens.
And it's not only got regular trash collection...
...it's gonna have single stream recycling.
We also have a brush collection program.
We have a separate metals collection program.
And one of the things we've just added along with single stream is electronics recycling collection curbside.
The United States generates more than 230,000 kilograms of trash a year.
Of that, about 33% is recycled in one form or another.
In Arlington, Virginia, just outside Washington, recycling rate is 42%,...
...higher than the national average.
But that number can, and should go higher,...
...once people realize just how much stuff is recyclable.